cherub merci depuis ce début du mois de
janvier
[Musique]
j'essaye de d'honorer les fonctions pour
confié françois fillon et bernard acoyer
le secrétaire général comme secrétaire
général adjoint en charge des
fédérations à côté de mon ami et
collègue annie genevard et depuis
maintenant quasiment à moi je parcours
les fédérations pour les réunions pour
les voeux j'imagine comme chacun d'entre
vous et je leur ai moi aussi je veux
qu'on les applaudissent
c'est lui les secrétaires départementaux
et c'est fer départementaux adjoints qui
font un travail formidable pour notre
mouvement pour la primaire car sans les
républicains jamais l'organisation des
primaires n'aurait été possible et en
parcourant la france en parcourant aussi
ma région des hauts de france je pense à
mon président xavier bertrand je retire
je veux dire un enseignement de ce que
je peux entendre ici ou là et de ce que
nous disent et nous répète nos militants
et nos sympathisants
ils nous disent que nous devons tous
mettre notre énergie pour gagner
l'élection présidentielle n'ont pas de
2022 mais de 2017
ils disent que nous devons être motivé
pour être unis est confiant parce que
non seulement la victoire de françois
fillon et nécessité pour la france
mais quelle victoire de la majorité
parlementaire réformera enfin notre pays
qui peut penser en effet et c'est le bon
sens populaire même que nous pourrions
construire 4 ce soir sur la défaite de
mai et de juin prochain
qui peut penser en effet nationalement
comme localement que l'on peut bâtir
quelque chose sur un champ de ruines et
un champ de mines
qui peut penser en effet que la france
qui a trop souffert de 50 socialisme et
de monsieur hollande peut penser
aujourd'hui qu'elle peut se payer le
luxe d'attendre cinq ans supplémentaires
personne ne peut le penser car en 2022
il sera trop tard
il sera trop tard pour réformer le pays
il sera trop tard pour donner confiance
à notre jeunesse
il sera trop tard pour ne pas désespérer
définitivement les classes populaires il
sera trop tard pour redonner du pouvoir
d'achat et du travail des ouvriers à
notre industrie il sera trop tard pour
encourager nos entrepreneurs
il sera trop tard pour relever notre
économie toute notre énergie et les
grandes doit être utilisé pour faire
gagner françois fillon la victoire doit
être notre combat quotidien et le
service des fédérations cher bernard
sera au service
évidemment de la campagne de notre
candidat l'ensemble de ses militants
pour organiser en lien total avec
l'équipe de campagne de françois fillon
la victoire de françois fillon et de sa
future majorité parlementaire
j'ai eu l'honneur d'être le directeur de
campagne de nicolas sarkozy
ce fut un très grand honneur pour moi ce
fut une très belle campagne
aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
nicolas sarkozy n'a plus directeur de
campagne il a plus de porte parole il
n'a pas non plus d'héritier mais il a eu
un message notamment le sort du premier
tour de l'élection primaire
il a encouragé la famille politique qui
l'a reconstruit à rester unis et à faire
tout faire pour la victoire de françois
villon la défaite
la défaite que nous pourrions avoir
s'ils nous étions désunis si nous
n'écouterons pas le message du président
sarkozy
cette défaite non seulement soit une
grande fête pour notre famille politique
mais serait un crime contre notre pays
alors c'est vrai que les français sont
impatients qui sont contestataires bien
souvent français varie mais les français
d'un futur sont motivés attendent
espèrent un gaulliste à nouveau à la
tête du pays et le gaullisme c'est le
rassemblement
c'est aussi fidèle au message du général
de gaulle qui souvenez-vous en 1943 et
cette phrase va très bien notre candidat
va très bien à nos candidats et va très
bien l'ensemble des militantes soyons
fermes pure et fidèle car au bout du
monde il ya la plus grande gloire celle
des hommes qui n'ont pas cédé
je remercie
[Applaudissements]